[Musique]
merci brossa vous pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes nouveau sénateur de
Paris membre du groupe communiste et
toujours porte-parole du Parti
communiste français on va évidemment
revenir sur votre arrivée au Sénat
est-ce que vous attendez de ce mandat
mais d'abord un mot sur l'actualité on
l'a vu Emmanuel Macron est toujours
encore c'est hier devant les élus de l
il a prononcer le mot d'autonomie il a
dit souhaiter que la Corse entre dans la
constitution vous aussi tout de ce qu'on
entend par autonomie pour l'instant
quand j'écoute Emmanuel Macron tout cela
reste extrêmement flou s'il s'agit par
exemple de permettre aux élus cororse de
disposer de nouveaux outils pour lutter
contre la spéculation immobilière
évidemment que j'y suis favorable
simplement ce sont d'ailleurs des outils
qui seraient utiles non pas seulement
pour la Corse mais aussi par exemple
pour le Pays-Basque ou pour Paris donc
s'il s'agit par exemple de mettre en
place une espèce de nouvelle boîte à
outils pour lutter contre la chaireté
des prix pour encadrer les prix du
foncier bien sûr que nous accompagnerons
tout cela s'il s'agit d'autres choses
nous regarderons de plus près jusqu'où
il faut aller pour vous sur l'autonomie
pour moi la seule question qui doit nous
guider la seule boussole que nous devons
avoir c'est l'amélioration de la vie
quotidienne des Corses c'est la lutte
contre les inégalités sociales qui font
rage en Corse c'est ça le seul sujet or
aujourd'hui vous avez déjà un certain
nombre d'adaptation en Corse par exemple
sur l'essence sur les produits
pétroliers vous avez une TVA qui est
inférieure elle est inférieure de 7
points encore par rapport à ce qu'on a
sur le continent et le prix à la pompe
en Corse il est plus cher donc bien sûr
il y a le prix du transport mais ça
n'explique pas tout vous avez entre les
deux des gens qui se gavent donc la
réalité c'est que l'adaptation locale
n'est pas la seule réponse au problème
et donc si on a envie de s'attaquer à la
question du pouvoir d'achat des Corses
on ne le fera pas qu'à coup de manœuvre
institutionnelle on a besoin de vraies
politiques publiqu on a besoin que
l'État il contribue certains élus cors
et certains cors demandent plus il
demandent la reconnaissance du peuple
Corse il demandent de la coofficialité
de la LAN Corse est-ce que pour vous ce
sont des lignes rouges il y a déjà
aujourd'hui l'enseignement du Corse dans
les écoles dans les écoles publiques
d'ailleurs en Corse contrairement à ce
qui se
passe oui c'est vrai nous nous sommes
comment dire pour nous ça n'est pas ça
le sujet principal pour nous le
principal sujet c'est la vie quotidienne
des Corses c'est la question du pouvoir
d'achat parce que la Corse en réalité
subit toutes les difficultés qu'on a sur
le continent dans ce domaine en pire et
donc c'est sur ça qu'il faut à nos yeux
concentrer l'essentiel des effs en tout
cas nous rentrons en tout cas nous
rentrons dans ce débat sans préjugés
sans jugement Atif et nous jugerons sur
pièces ce que j'allais vous demander
parce que vous serez amené à vous
prononcer puisque évidemment le le
Parlement devra trancher à quellees
condition vous voteriez vous le texte et
l'entrée de l'accord dans la
Constitution d'abord nous attendrons de
de de voir ce qu'il y a et par ailleurs
nous sommes attachés au fait qu'au final
ce soit les cors qui puisse trancher
cette question et d'ailleurs la logique
voudrait à mes yeux que tout ça puisse
se conclure par un référendum au cours
duquel on donne la parole au cors et on
leur permet de trancher définitivement
ces questions autre sujet c'est
Élisabeth Band qui a dégainé le 493 sur
le premier texte de la session la loi de
programmation des finances publics vous
n'êtes pas surpris elle avait pas
d'autrre choix bien sûr qu'elle avait
d'autres choix c'est c'est c'est devenu
le le luckyc du 493 elle dégaine le 493
plus vite que que que son nombre la
réalité surtout c'est qu'on a un
gouvernement qui contraint parce qu'il
n'arrive pas à convaincre et que faute
d'avoir discuté avec les avec les
oppositions et au-delà des oppositions
faute d'entendre ce qui se passe dans la
société le gouvernement ne fonctionne
que par l'autoritarisme et donc que par
le 493 on ne gouverne pas un pays
sereinement en dégainant des 493 tous
les qu matins ou tous les quatre soirs
en l'occurrence donc je n'y suis pas du
tout favorable et puis surtout le fond
de ce budget est un très mauvais budget
un budget qui va représenter des saigné
supplémentaires notamment dans les
services publics et donc nous ne pouvons
que nous y opposer mais le Conseil des
ministres a déjà autorisé ellisabeth
borne à recourir au 493 pour le budget
du coup dans quel état d'esprit vous
allez aborder les discussions
budgétaires nous allons engager ces
discussions budgétaires avec une grande
combativité parce que vous savez il y a
bien sûr malgré le coup près du 493 qui
est déjà mais mais mais mais ça n'est
pas pour autant qu'il faut baisser la
garde et donc nous allons rester
extrêmement combatif la vie ne s'arrête
pas d'ailleurs au Parlement ni à
l'Assemblée nationale ni au Sénat et et
et je ne pense pas que les Français
supporteront longtemps cette politique
d'autant que ce qu'on nous annonce c'est
non seulement des couples pour cette
année mais on nous annonce pour 2025
pour 2026 pour 2027 trois saignés
supplémentaires de 12 milliards d'euros
dans les dépenses publiques avec
l'objectif de d'atteindre les 3 % de
déficit de de enfin d'atteindre un
déficit qui atteindrait 3 % du PIB du
fait des contraintes de l'Union
européenne donc il est bien évident que
face à ça nous n'allons pas rester sans
réagir parce qu'au final c'est l'école
c'est l'hôpital comme d'habitude qui
trinqueront la gauche dépose une motion
de censure c'est pas la première sauf
qu'elle semble n'avoir aucune chance de
passer il sera examiné dans les
prochaines heures est-ce que ça souligne
pas la faiblesse des opposition à faire
tomber le gouvernement ah je pense
surtout que c'est
l'enchaînement successif de 493 qui
traduit la faiblesse du gouvernement
parce que si le gouvernement a recours
au 493 c'est précisément parce qu'il
sait qu'il n'est pas majoritaire il
n'est majoritaire ni à l'Assemblée
nationale ni dans le pays sauf qu'elle
engage la responsabilité de son
gouvernement et que vous n'arrivez pas à
le renverser mais il n'a pas de majorité
dans le pays pour mener ses politique
qui pourrissent la vie de la grande
majorité de nos concitoyens et regardez
quand même l'état d'ébullition dans
laquelle et et et et notre peuple
aujourd'hui des des Français qui par
millions n'arrivent pas à boucler leur
fin de mois qui sont confrontés à une
inflation qui augmente de jour en jour
et donc nous notre rôle d'élu c'est de
faire écho à cette réalité là et de
proposer des solutions je voudrais juste
citer une solution très concrète sur la
question de l'inflation c'est
l'indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation Fabien Roussel a fait cette
proposition il y a des mois ça se
pratique en Belgique c'est ce qui permet
que le travail paye et que votre paye
celle qui revient du travail ne soit pas
dévorée par le niveau des prix que le le
gouvernement se saisisse de cette
proposition pour qu'on permette enfin
aux Français de sortir la tête de l'eau
on va parler de vous Yan brossa vous
allez passer de la Mairie de Paris au
couloir du Sénat vous nous direz vous
allez nous dire comment vous envisagez
votre mandat d'abord Quentin calmé nous
rejoint il va dresser votre
[Musique]
portrait bonjour Quentin bonjour orien
bonjour Yan brossin bonjour et Quentin
yann brossin est donc devenu sénateur
Dimanche c'est la dernière étape pour le
moment d'une ascension en politique
depuis la fin des années 2000 c'est ça
on est remonté au plus loin que l'on
pouvait dans les archives de la
rédaction de publ Sénat on a retrouvé un
reportage qui vous a consacré les
nouveaux visages du PCF le document date
de 2008 vous n'avez que 28 ans vous êtes
déjà le président du groupe communiste
au Conseil de Paris plus jeune président
de groupe de ce conseil dans l'histoire
ce jour-là vous rendez visite à une
association les petits frères des
Pauvres on regarde un extrait
Yann brossa est l' des nouveaux visages
du Parti communiste et il attend
beaucoup du congrès de ce weekend après
des mois difficiles pour sa formation le
l'enjeu de ce congrès et au-delà de ce
congrès c'est de faire en sorte qu'on
est à nouveau un parti communiste qui se
voit et ça suppose effectivement qu'on
bosse et et qu'à nouveau on soit sur le
terrain qu'on soit au plus près des gens
moi c'est ça que j'ai envie qu'on fasse
vous étiez déjà très à l'aise devant les
caméras mais donc conseiller de Paris
vous êtes bienveillant quand même vous
participez à la campagne d'An dalgo en
2014 les communistes se Rall dès le
premier tour à nidalgo dans un moment
compliqué à gauche car en 2014 on est un
an et demi après l'élection de François
Hollande on regarde une autre archive de
Public Sénat un accord qui n'avait
pourtant rien d'évident depuis
l'élection de François Hollande le PCF
et le Front de Gauche se montrent très
critique envers le gouvernement c'est
donc une rupture avec cette stratégie
Yann brossa chef de fil des communistes
parisiens intègre même l'équipe de
campagne d'ny dalgo mais il veut tout de
même rassurer s anciens allés le Front
de Gauche continue continuera euh et je
crois qu'il ne faut pas comment dire
dramatiser l'enjeu
autour d'une différence d'appréciation
sur les élections municipales
ouis une archive d'octobre 2013 on est
bien 6 mois avant l'élection municipale
à Paris et anidalgo qui sera élu en
avril 2014 vous devenez un des adjoints
à la mairie de Paris en charge des
sujets de logement un de vos thèmes de
prix
vous êtes un des élus les plus mobilisés
en faveur de la régulation des
plateformes on pense bien sûr à
Airbnb cela vous vaudra plusieurs passes
d'armes d'ailleurs avec le gouvernement
en avril 2021 vous expliquz que depuis
2015 Paris a perdu 30000 logements qui
ont basculé d'habitation à hôtel
clandestin cela a contribué à
restreindre l'offre locative avez-vous
dit à l'époque et depuis 2018 Yan brossa
est une figure importante du Parti
communiste voilà désigné porte-parole du
PCF en 2018 Yan brossa vous êtes un
proche de Fabien Roussel désormais vous
serez même son directeur de la campagne
présidentielle l' dernière et vous vous
avez été le candidat aux élections
européennes en 2019 votre score 2,5 %
alors dernière étape dimanche dernier
nos reporters étaient à l'hôtel de ville
au moment de l'annonce des résultats la
gauche qui réalise h sièges sur 12 à
pourvoir dans la capitale un gain net
d'un siège c'est donc la joie que l'on
voit autour du camp anidalgo de la
majorité municipale et donc vous êtes
élu sénateur de Paris sur cette liste
d'union de la gauche comment avez-vous
vécu cette élection vous devenez un élu
national est-ce que pour vous ça change
quelque chose enfin en tout cas ça ne
change pas ma manière de faire de la
politique moi j'ai toujours voulu faire
de la politique pour être utile pour
être utile au plus grand nombre à ceux
qui sont souvent peu représenté dans
dans les assemblées électives et donc
non j'ai je garde ma même boussole
l'envie de de lutter contre les
inégalités contre les injustices
sociales tout ce qui a fait que à l'âge
de 17 ans j'ai adhéré au Parti
communiste il s'est déroulé beaucoup
d'années depuis et j'ai gardé les mêmes
convictions vous étiez précoce en
politique vous vous le reconnaissez vous
premier président d'un groupe au Conseil
de Paris c'est vous qui détenait le
record comment expliquer cette précocité
sans doute précisément parce que je me
suis engagé quand j'étais tout jeune je
me suis engagé plus de 10 ans avant
d'être élu à l'Hôtel de Ville hein
j'avais 17 ans c'était en 1997 j'ai
adhéré au parti communiste parce que
j'ai rencontré des gens dans mon
quartier qui se battaient pour la
défense d'un hôpital et j'ai trouvé que
ces gens étaient des gens bien qui se
battaient pour des pour des cause juste
qui faisait ça comment dire gratuitement
sans attendre rien en échange si ce
n'est de mener leur leur combat et et
d'obtenir une victoire mais pour le
reste ces gens m m'ont plusu je les ai
aimé et donc j'ai adhéré au Parti
communiste voilà et je suis resté fidèle
à mon parti depuis plus d'une vingtaine
d'années vous êtes arrivé au Sénat la
semaine dernière du coup en début de
semaine même lundi c'est c'est difficile
quand on on arrive au Sénat de de
prendre ses marques vous avez été un peu
impressionné quelles ont été vos
impressions j'ai été bien accueilli en
tout cas tout le monde m'a dit que c'est
une belle maison et et c'est le
sentiment que j'ai eu en tout cas je
suis très très heureux de pouvoir
prolonger mes engagements dans cette
dans cette assemblée et d'ailleurs les
sénateurs communistes sont reconnus
depuis longtemps pour pour leur travail
je pense notamment à la commission
d'enquête lancée par Elana Assassi sur
les cabinets de conseil on peut être
minoritaire nous sommes minoritaires au
Sénat et nous le resterons vra
semblablement longtemps et être dans le
même temps utile et je pense que les
sénateurs communistes l'ont prouvé j'ai
envie de suivre leur chemin on disiez
vous étiez très engagé sur les questions
de logement à la mairie de Paris élu
d'ailleurs au logement est-ce que vous
allez continuer à porter ces thèmesl à
la Chambre du Parlement vous le pensez
ah ça c'est sûr je je ne sais pas encore
dans quelle commission je siègerai mais
ce qui est sûr c'est que je prêterai une
attention particulière à ces question de
logement puis vous imaginez bien que
dans cette période où le logement est en
crise c'est devenu d'ailleurs un vrai à
sujet politique où tout le monde
reconnaît que le gouvernement a échoué
totalement sur cette question je ne vais
pas rester silencieux sur celle-ci donc
bien sûr je vais parler logement je vais
me mêler de de ces questions-là parce
qu'on ne peut pas à la fois dire que le
principal problème du pays c'est le
pouvoir d'achat et dans le même temps ne
pas s'attaquer à cette question du
logement alors que le logement est le
premier poste de dépensees des ménages
donc on a besoin d'une vraie politique
du logement il y a d'ailleurs beaucoup
de parlementaires au sein du Sénat qui
s'intéressent à ces sujets y compris à
droite je pense à à Dominique est a ça
sonne et je suis convaincu que
absolument et je suis convaincu que sur
ces sujets du logement on peut
rassembler au-delà même du clivage
droite gauche pour défendre le le
logement pour tous et on le disait vous
avez eu comme cela des passes d'armes
avec le gouvernement sur le dossier de
Airbnb faut-il aller plus loin dans la
régulation de ces plateformes est-ce que
vous vous pourriez soutenir vous un
cadre législatif plus contraignant pour
ces plateformes mais je je le demande
ardemment depuis des années j'ai encore
fait partir un courrier au ministre sur
ce sujet il y a quelques semaines il y a
au moins deux sujets il y a le premier
sujet qui devra être discuté dans le
cadre du du projet de loi de finance qui
est la question de la fiscalité des
locations touristiques cela fait des
mois que le gouvernement annonce sa
volonté d'en finir avec la niche fiscale
qui profite aux gens qui louent sur
Airbnb vous vous rendez compte
qu'aujourd'hui vous payez moins d'impôts
quand vous louez un logement sur Airbnb
que quand vous louez en location
classique c'est complètement stupide
donc premièrement finir avec ça et
deuxièmement la question des passoirs
des passoirs énergétiques puisque il est
prévu d'interdire à la location les
passoirs thermiques en location
classique en revanche c'est permis pour
des donc on a là une forme de de
concurrence déloyal qui profitent aux
locations touristiques au détriment de
la location normale on va parler des
persoirs term dans quelques secondes
avec la presse régionale Quentin vous
aviez une dernière question non c'est
pas de dernière question moi j'en ai une
parce que évidemment il y a les sujets
que vous voulez défendre et puis il y a
les grands textes qui vont arriver le
premier grand texte que vous allez
examiner c'est dans un petit peu plus
d'un mois c'est la loi immigration on
sait qu'ici au Sénat il y a une ligne
rouge c'est la question des titres de
séjour dans les métiers en tension c'est
la ligne rouge des sénateurs LR comment
vous comptez peser dans ce débat vous
les sénateurs communiste bah en partant
du réel tout simplement et donc nous
nous continuerons à défendre la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier on peut pas admettre que des des
centaines de milliers de gens qui
travaillent dans des secteurs
effectivement tendus je pense à
l'hôtellerie je pense à la restauration
soit dépourvu de tout droit et la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier j'y insiste c'est à la fois bon
pour les premiers concernés parce que ça
leur permettra d'avoir accès à leur
droit mais c'est bon pour le monde du
travail dans son ensemble parce que
maintenir dans la clandestinité des
centaines de milliers de travailleurs
c'est fabriquer du dumping social et
c'est tirer tout le monde vers le bas
donc la régularisation est une solution
et j'ai bon espoir que nos arguments
finissent par porter et le gouvernement
qui semble aller dans votre sens hein
qui ne souhaite pas retirer cette mesure
du texte est-ce que si elle y figure
toujours vous le voterez ce texte on
verra bien on verra sur pièce c'est et
on verra y compris dans quel état ce
texte sort de de de son examen au Sénat
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que sur
la régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier nous ne lâcherons pas à tout à
l'heure Quentin merciian oui à tout à
l'heure merci merci à vous on va
reparler des questions de logement
puisqu'on regarde l'actualité avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
aller à Orléan où on retrouve Alexandre
charier bonjour Alexandre merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous journaliste à La
République du Centre et Alexandre
justement vous voulez revenir sur ces
questions de logement et notamment sur
les tensions sur le marché
locatif oui tout à fait comme dans
beaucoup de grandes villes à Orléan le
le marché locatif est actuellement assez
tendu notamment à cause de la hausse des
taux de de crédit qui empêchent les
familles de basculer vers vers la
propriété euh à cela s'ajoute ce que ce
que ce qu'a dit déjà Yan brossa
concernant la chasse au passeoir
thermique on a vu que Bruno LEM avait
demandé une sorte de moratoire sur cette
question cette semaine avant de
rétropédaler est-ce que est-ce que dans
ce contexte tendu finalement c'est une s
mauvaise idée que ça et et si oui si
c'est une mauvaise idée qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire aujourd'hui pour assouplir ce
ce marché de des locations qui empêchent
bah qui qui rendent difficile
aujourd'hui l'accès au logement
allezy aujourd'hui le gouvernement nous
nous confronte à une espèce de de de
d'aporie parce
que il est prévu au cours de deux
échéances 2025 et 2028 d'interdire à la
location les passeoirs thermiques
c'était la loi climat et
résilience et donc à partir de là comme
le travail n'a pas été fait pour rénover
ses logements ou alors à un rythme
tellement faible que ça ne suffit pas le
gouvernement a deux solutions soit il
retardent l'échéance et donc ça veut
dire qu'on va laisser des gens louer des
passoirs thermiques donc vivre dans des
passoirs thermiques avec d'ailleurs des
charges d'énergie qui n'arrêtent pas
d'exploser en ce moment des logements
mal isolés soit à
[Musique]
l'inverse qu'estce à l'inverse retire à
la location ses logements CR on se
retrouve avec des tensions
supplémentaires sur le marché donc la
seule solution pour moi la seule
solution viable c'est de mettre les
bouchées doubles sur la rénovation
énergétique des
logements aujourd'hui des rénovations
massives on en fait 66000 par an
rénovation massive de logement il faudra
en faire 1 million par an 1 million par
an d'ici 2028 pour être dans les clous
donc on a surtout besoin d'accélérer la
rénovation énergétique des logements et
nous ferons des amendements
visant à abonder davantage tous les
dispositifs qui permettent de de rénover
les logements Alexandre vous avez une
autre question sur un autre sujet
puisque vous allez revenir sur les
sénatoriales qui ont eu lieu on le
rappelle dimanche
dernier une question peut-être un peu
plus politique on a pu constater dans le
Loiret comme dans différents
départements que LFI n'a pas trouvé
d'accord avec ses ses partenaires au
niveau des sénatorial on s'oriente vers
la même configuration pour les pour les
européennes avec des listes distincte il
se passe pas une seule journée sans sans
une passe d'arme médiatique entre entre
Fabien Roussel et Jean-Luc Mélenchon ma
question elle est simple est-ce que de
votre point de vue il est pas temps de
d'entériner la fin de la nuupes qui
correspondait à un moment celui des
législatives 2022 et et de constater que
ce moment il est il est passé et que ça
ne correspond plus à la situation
actuelle moi j'ai toujours dit les
choses franchement et Fabien Roussel
aussi l'anupè c'était un accord pour les
élections législatives d'ailleurs il y a
pas la nupè au Sénat et par ailleurs j'y
insiste quand même il y a eu un certain
nombre de listes d'union au sénatorial
effectivement sans la France insoumise
mais qui ont rassemblé les autres
composantes de la gauche moi je pense
surtout plutôt que d'écrire la chronique
de la fin de la nuupè qu'on a besoin
d'écrire la chronique d'une union de la
gauche gagnante et moi ce que je
souhaite c'est que nous puissions
construire un rassemblement gagnant la
nup mais dans cette union de la gauche
gagnante il y a la France insoumise pour
vous il y a tout ceux qu'il souhaitent
mais en tout cas ça doit eux ils vous
appelleent à l'Union mais pour les
sénatoriales ils voulent l'Union aussi
c'est vous qui avez ça doit être une
union dans le respect de chacune et de
chacun et pas à coup d'insulte et pas à
coup d'oucase et donc je pense que cette
union là elle reste à construire et donc
nous ce que nous souhaitons avec Fabien
Roussel c'est tendre la main à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui veulent
construire une union gagnante laanupes
ne nous a pas permis de gagner les
élections législatives aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale nous avons un
parlementaire sur quatre qui est de
gauche donc c'est nous avons progressé
par rapport aux législatives
précédentees qui était désastreuse mais
enfin on n'a pas gagné loin de là et je
pense et je pense qu'il y a un potentiel
dans notre société qui peut nous
permettre de gagner il y a trois
Français sur quatre qui ont soutenu la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites donc ça montre qu'il y a des
tas de gens qui veulent une juste
rémunération du travail qui veulent la
justice sociale qui veulent du service
public et c'est autour de cette majorité
là de cette majorité de gens qu'il faut
qu'on soit capable de r mais pourquoi
vous n'avez pas gagné selon vous
clairement est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la
France insoumise est un repoussir parce
que j'ai pensé je pense qu'aux dernières
élections législatives sur un certain
nombre de sujets on a inutilement clivé
que sur les sujets de de sécurité de
justice on a besoin de retravailler pour
comprendre aussi l'aspiration à la
sécurité de nos concitoyens notamment
dans les quartiers populaires dans nos
villages aussi on a besoin de parler de
ces sujets il n'est pas utile de cliver
en permanence sur ces questions mais
est-ce que c'est un repoussoir Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Mo je je ne m'exprimerai pas
comme ça
et et je laisse à d'autres ce type
d'expression moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que nous soyons rassembleurs et
que nous soyons dans un état d'esprit
qui permettent de gagner on peut pas
continuer avec la politique qui est
menée par Emmanuel Macron en ce moment
ou par un éventuel succès mais est-ce
que là le Parti communiste n'est pas
dans un entre deux vous ne sortez pas
clairement de la nuupe mais en même
temps on voit les attaques sont
virulentes entre Fabien Roussel et
jean-luch Mélenchon on a compris que
Fabien Roussel contestait la ligne de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon pourquoi ne pas dire
clairement nous on n plus dans laanupe
mais parce qu'il y a des tas de gens
avec lesquels nous nous voulons
continuer à travailler au sein de
l'anupe et puis surtout notre sujet ça
n'est pas d'en finir avec cette alliance
là notre sujet c'est comment on réussit
à élargir cette alliance et à obtenir
qu'elle soit victorieuse lors des
prochaines échéances l' c'est pas de
casser la baraque l'idée c'est de faire
mieux comme
dirait dirait jeanluc Mélenchon faisons
mieux je suis convaincu que nous pouvons
faire mieux ils sont pas condamnés à
s'entendre Jean-Luc Mélenchon et Fabien
Rous nous sommes tous condamnés à nous
entendre mais pour s'entendre il faut du
respect mutuel et il faut être
capable d'adopter une posture
rassembleuse encore un peu de travailou
vous avez une autre question sur les
sénatorial Alexandre ou pas non je vous
remercie bon alors on va regarder votre
une on va continuer en parler on va
regarder votre une Alexandre entreprise
du Loiret les faillites redouble c'est à
la Une de votre journal merci beaucoup
Alexandre charier d'avoir été avec nous
de la République du Centre justement sur
les sénatoriales la France insoumise dit
il y a eu une alliance entre communiste
socialiste écologistes total la gauche
sénatori a perdu 10 sièges en excluant
les listes de en excluant les candidats
de la France insoumise est-ce qu'ils
n'ont pas raison mais je comprends pas
la la gauche sénatoriale a gagné 10
sièges au Sénat elle a pas perdu 10
sièges elle a gagné 10 sièges
puisqu'elle fait 10 sièges de plus que
lors du Sénat pr mais ils disent que
vous auriez pu faire 10 sièges encore de
plus que vous auriez pu faire mieux s'il
y avait toute la Gauche unie avec des si
on met Paris en bouteille et le Parisien
que je suis a bien l'expression en tête
non non nous avons gagné 10 sièges et
d'ailleurs quand je compare la
représentation de la gauche à
l'Assemblée nationale et la
représentation de la gauche au Sénat
nous sommes proportionnellement plus
nombreux au Sénat donc j'ai plutôt le
sentiment que notre rassemblement avec
les communistes les écologistes et les
socialistes a fonctionné et d'ailleurs
donc la gauche aujourd'hui elle est
gagnante sans la France ins sou gagnante
on n pas gagné au Sénat mais en tout cas
la configuration dans laquelle nous
avons été au sénatorial nous a permis de
progresser et tant mieux à la Fête de
l'Humanité il y a eu un débat entre
Fabien Roussel et Édouard Philippe
est-ce que vous avez approuvé le choix
de ce débat quel était l'objectif
parce que je pense que c'était
l'occasion de débattre
entre eux une personnalité de gauche
populaire la personnalité de gauche la
plus populaire en France et la
personnalité de droite la plus populaire
donc du coup ça permettait d'avoir un
affrontement clair entre deux visions de
la société extrêmement différentes
d'ailleurs ce débat a permis de montrer
des différen importantes sur la question
des retraites sur la question de la
rémunération du travail sur la question
du service publ et je pense qu'on a
besoin d'un retour du clivage droite
gauche sur un certain nombre de sujets
donc je pense que ça ça c'est un
adversaire redoutable un potentiel
adversaire redoutable édard Philippe en
202 bien sûr c'est un adversaire très
sérieux il est de droite
incontestablement et nous devons
l'affronter avec bien sûr du respect dû
à à tout responsable mais dans le même
temps avec fermeté et je crois que
Fabien Roussel l'a fait pendant ce débat
cé un très bon débat très intéressant et
tous ceux qui n'y ont pas assisté ont
raté quelque chose il y a eu un fait
marquant aussi dimanche soir de résultat
des sénatoriales c'est le retour du
rassemblement national au Sénat alors
ils ont trois sénateurs mais ils ont
augmenté leur voix dans de nombreux
territoires et on rappelle que ce sont
les élus locaux qui votent lors de ces
sénatoriales est-ce que c'est pas la
preuve que le RN est en train de réussir
son implantation locale vous savez ce
que je vois aussi par exemple dans le
Pas de Calais qui est un département où
le rassemblement national a
malheureusement une implantation
importante y compris Madame Le Pen
d'ailleurs c'est que nous nous avons
deux sénateurs alors que nous nous en
avions un la fois précédente et que nous
avons rassemblé 25 % des voix sur la
liste de de Cathy apursop polii donc
bien sûr c'est un combat difficile c'est
un combat pied à pied mais les
communistes sont ceux qui sont les plus
à même de faire reculer le rassemblement
national et d'ailleurs aux dernières
élections législative c'est un
communiste qui a battu le rassemblement
national dans la circonscription de
l'Ance donc je pense que nous sommes les
mieux placés parce que nous défendons la
France du travail parce que nous sommes
ceux qui sont les plus en contact avec
les populations nous sommes les mieux
placés pour faire reculer le RN merci
Anne Brossard merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité